hey soy sauce Oh mom doesn't see this
might winter do I just do I go on so
I've been like addicted to tick tock
lately I've found this challenge and I
thought it would be cool if I surprised
the single guys with it I think you know
what you're talking about yeah let's go
see if we can murder
I've been eating cake oozing all week
because you can take this well for me
come on Blake you got a sec yeah what's
up
come on let's take this one real quick
everybody say do I have that done line
though come on it'll be fun
come on take these like single guys
unite come on so me my gang I work just
got pulled up by this guy how the soy
sauce challenge where you put soy sauce
ketchup cranberry sauce on your balls
don't zoom in on me like that okay we're
going in order of the 50 calorie
challenge yes you are the last one
that's all you gotta thank you
challenges series keep coming at me for
for not doing these challenges so I'm
gonna do this one this all right so no
more ignoring mean comments doing white
yeah what each flavor we are we making a
buck they know internet think about this
content I went to college for this are
you doing it right now is this supposed
to be like way instantaneous oh it
doesn't take us it happened pretty quick
so I know you gotta do the much winter
do I just do I gotta go on
all right so I would say no to the soy
sauce 50 K challenge I place third even
I'm up next yeah boy yeah I don't know
once again just the smells deceive you a
little bit you think about it but I'm up
next I got second place because I'm the
champ no no that makes sense I'm the
only one in the world belt so I think I
will die I would die you were always by
Shawn Shawn I would die somebody you go
darling darling die your upper thigh a
soy sauce wait did you wipe I did what
oh my god I was thinking the same thing
I don't know that was another quick
tradition you hear what is more than
shiny so the soy sauce is like mutt has
a much more serious smell I think it's
just your smell tricking your mind I
don't think you're actually tasting one
you won the challenge yeah so your
reward is you only have to do one when
when try one try just one try okay you
pick the sauce you pick whatever you
want but you gotta go full teabag teabag
multiband know what girl for the rest of
the day smell like whatever how about
baby lunch something with your soy sauce
I'll submerged in the soy sauce because
that's the one that gave the taste I'm
gonna do it pre-loss bling all right
throw away my baby boy whoa I just mean
I just need one I just need one bag no
listen I'm letting celebrate oh it's
okay oh I'm letting it soak because I
want to taste okay listen
maybe I'm smelling it no yeah I think I
can taste it yo it was the soap and we
were done okay you got a full submerge I
think we have I think we got something I
think so okay just to be sure
dunk him in the cranberry too just to be
sure to be sure to tuck him in all three
I love how we're doing this behind it I
do get the lotion I'm doing they're not
giving it the lotion figure that suppose
nothing ketchup was nothing
I start with twins we'll move over the
couch living yo I'm dedicated
that's the life if I swap more and they
go deep no no good things experiment
did you disinfect your fingers yes
before you put I'm getting every area
off the any of them tastes like that's
not working out Andrew like let's get a
nice good nice Jesus but you knew he was
naked behind a curtain you just go
closer that's how close I've only got
smelly so how do they smell kind of
deals with the taste a little bit but
there's some fruit each in your mouth
there's some fruit each up here there's
there's some footage can we get a second
trying to cram grass but these we want
to make sure
this because I think I'm about to read
it like it's not in my mouth but it's
like that here somewhere here somewhere
like no like it's like in my sinus Regis
is ever been how that work you never use
a bathroom you okay yo that's a boo-boo
super situation okay that's a good but
is it in my head is it like it's in the
back of my neck what is it like a mental
thing hey Teddy before you surely sit
how much more soy sauce let me show you
good I'm good I'll save it for my lunch
bro you got any thoughts on that I'm not
interested to try thank you sure you
fully washable so you don't get a yeast
infection because the sugar from the soy
sauce can get really warm between your
legs
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]